le message est très clair c'est nous qui
commandons et on fait ce qu'on veut ce
genre de menace est devenu un classique
en corse une île frappée par la violence
de la mafia c'est une bande de 100
anglaise lui au départ et qui se sont
mis à avoir
des ambitions gros voyous et pour
pouvoir se faire une place chez gros
boyaux pour assassiner les gens il est
gangréné par une grosse centaine de
personnes qui ont un pouvoir de nuisance
terrible et je pense que les gens
veulent en sortir
je parle pour ma génération de ce que je
suis assez jeune et j'ai fini de grandir
dans une corse où on a peur de dire ce
que l'on pense même si on savait plus
vraiment qui a assassiné notre ami on
est dans un rapport de force si on
obligé de calculer tout ça dans nos
pages à dire mourir tout de suite
[Musique]
en corse on a pu rencontrer ceux qui
dénoncent l'emprise de la mafia à visage
découvert depuis 2004 plus de 450
homicides ou tentatives d'homicides ont
été recensés sur l'île la corse est
devenue la première région européenne en
nombre de règlements de comptes
c'est à proximité de cet établissement
que maxime susini a été tué ce matin au
pays de l'omerta les langues se délient
depuis la mort de maxime susini en
septembre dernier maxime susini
appartenait au mouvement nationaliste
il était aussi connu pour son engagement
pour la préservation de l'environnement
et ça ça dérangeait les mafieux de cette
région du sud de la corse
pour l'oncle de maxime ce sont ces
engagements qui ont coûté la vie vous
avez une petite bande de voyous mais
veut dire de petite envergure qui a
commencé à s'organiser à cargèse autour
de la drogue dans un premier temps et
puis qui a commencé avant des ambitions
plus importante le racket et maxime
s'est opposée ils ont fait quelque chose
qui est irréversible ils seront à en
payer les conséquences
il ya des personnes qui n'accepteront
pas que ces crapules et s'empare du
temps car gyan toute personne
aujourd'hui encore ce qui lève la tête
qui lève les yeux qui ouvre la bouche
est susceptible d'être en danger
mais de toute manière je ne crois pas
plus en danger que si je ne parlais pas
ce qui nous a malgré tout encouragé
cette légende en leur nom leur numéro de
téléphone leurs courriels
ça c'est une chose qui est pas évidente
on board
il est important qu'on fasse un petit à
petit une petite analyse de ce qui est
en train de se passer encore ce point il
faut savoir que cette banque vérifie qu
a fait une liste de gens à tuer
s'intitule en réalité ont massivement
été le premier sur la liste donc là il
ya une urgence de sécurité pour les
personnes en question là on n'est même
pas à proposer un modèle alternatif on
en est on est sur la défensive
c'est à dire sur vivre physiquement et
survivre socialement moi je ne sais pas
qui a tué ma mère m'a si moi je ne sais
pas il y avait bien des faits qui sont
graves
il ya des faits qui sont moins graves
mais qui sont au quotidien mais qui
alimente ce système on en a tous dans
nos familles on est apparentée avec des
gens qui sont qui ont honte on dit que
ça allait passer de la paix et on fait
avec ce n'est pas pour autant nos amis
on est on n'entre pas en collaboration
on ne va pas leur apporter une caution
morale et là je crois quand même c'est
que dans cette ville bonne nuit à
distance ce par rapport à ces gens là
pour nous ce sera pas possible de vendre
ça ça se promener dans la rue
profitez du soleil et du vent etc ça ne
sera pas possible ça sera invivable pour
le tous ses précédents l'etrat rivella
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'appât du
gain qui compte c'est fait des valeurs
des principes contrairement à ce que tu
y avait à l'époque et je pense qu enfin
moi je parle pour ma génération ce que
je suis assez jeune et j'ai pas envie de
grandir dans une corse où on a peur de
dire ce que l'on pense
sur quoi cela va déboucher en nous mêmes
on le maîtrise passe mais on doit mettre
en place une stratégie de récession m
la marque et toutes dans toutes ses
composantes sur la défensive on va bien
être d'une certaine manière
obligé de remettre en cause la façon
dont douze ou treize familles se sont
emparés du pouvoir économique en corse
quand on va faire des propositions
concrètes
je pense qu'on va le féminisme
chatouiller beaucoup de gens si les
citoyens sont les premières victimes de
la mafia le crime organisé s'attaque
aussi au maire le vin trop 2018
un homme cagoulé tirs sur les caméras de
surveillance de la mairie de s'entourer
là bas les terrains en bord de mer
valent de l'or
et ça attise toutes les convoitises on
voit toujours sur la façade les impacts
de petit plomb
le message est très clair c'est nous qui
commandons et on fait ce qu'on veut
la population elle ne peut être que
retranchés chez elle et constater qu'un
maire malgré son son pouvoir et son
autorité elle est bafouée au quotidien
et donc c'est ce sentiment d'impuissance
qu'on n'arrête pas de dénoncer depuis le
début
le problème de l'urbanisme encore ça
c'est le nerf de la guerre parce qu'à un
moment donné sur des régions qui sont
très convoités comme le littoral centuri
ont fait partie aussi c'est qu'on avait
ouvert à la spéculation pour rendre
constructibles certains secteurs au
détriment d'autres
et c'est là où le bât blesse et qu'à un
moment donné on privilégie l'intérêt
particulier de certaines personnes au
détriment de l'intérêt général
donc on a tiré à partir d'ici et une
partie des chevrotines on voit toujours
les impacts sur la barrière ou si on
comprend bien on tire on dit si il ya
quelqu'un qui sort à ce moment là là
c'est la chambre mont d'or je suis la
petite fenêtre c'est là où dans mes
enfants non mais je l'aï oui il ya
quelqu'un qui sort sur la place
[Musique]
on a peur au quotidien on a peur mais si
vous commencez à fonctionner avec la
peur et la réticence pour faire les
choses vous faites plus rien quoi vous
restez à la maison vous donner à la
maison et puis vous bougez plus c'est
pas du tout mon cas c'est pas c'est pas
ma façon de faire au quotidien
en corse même chez les anciens mafieux
ça sent la fin de l'omerta claude
chossat est un ancien de la brise de mer
un gang qui a régné pendant plus de 20
ans sur le nord de lille il se dit
repentis et quand nous l'avons filmé en
octobre 2019
il se cachait très loin de la corse moi
aujourd'hui quand j'entends certains
propos qui disent qu'en corse il n'y a
pas de mafia
ça me fait rire parce qu'en fait tout
démontre le contraire vous avez des
affaires qui ont touché les
collectivités des affaires qui ont
touché le conseil général des
fonctionnaires corrompus et tout ça
c'est c'est la définition c'est la
définition d'un système mafieux de
l'argent qui est réinjecté dans
l'économie locale dans des affaires tout
à fait légale pour moi on peut parler de
mafia oui quelqu'un arrive
ouvre une affaire la sphère commence à
avoir bonne presse et a fonctionné de
suite ça attire la convoitise des voyous
qui vont le faire approcher pour le
racketter s'ils n'acceptent pas à soi on
va le bastonner soit on va lui mettre
une charge explosive devant sa brasserie
où son restaurant pour qu'ils payent la
montée du degré de violence c'est parce
qu'en fait avant par le passé les rênes
était tenu par deux clans la brise de
mer au nord le le clan colonna au sud et
ses clans là en fait tu réussissais à
s'entendre et à établir une hiérarchie
aujourd'hui sa part un petit peu dans
tous les sens avec des équipes qui
arrivent en périphérie et qui sont
extrêmement violentes comme on peut voir
ces derniers temps notamment sur la
région ajaccienne et la région de
cargèse depuis notre tournage en octobre
2019 que je ça a été condamné à huit ans
de prison pour complicité d'assassinât
d'un des barons de la brise de mer
après le verdict sa femme a dénoncé un
jugement qui pourrait dissuader tous
ceux qui veulent briser l'omerta les
gens ne parleront pas parce que là on
prouve bien que les gens qui viennent de
parler mais en fait on les considère
comme rien le président a reconnu quand
même qu'il a servi quand même à la
justice
mais bon en attendant on lui a fait une
petite faveur mais il a été condamné
comme s'il était le baron de la brise de
mer